John Reid covers the Jags he was there
for last night's game he covers the Jags
for the Florida times-union and John
kind enough to join us this morning that
victory calm things down John I think
the does my wrong faking mother with the
Jaguars I think I hope they think so
okay a good window okay are we too far
down the road with Jalen Ramsey is there
any is there any chance for you know
salvaging this I think on the Jaguar
side it could be I think that does
Marone is not pretty much in this and in
this situation even though it look
looked like it was with the
confrontation on the sidelines I think
that management whatever his issues is I
it sounds like it could be hashed out of
the conversation but I think from here
in his podcast yesterday and just I kind
of think that he's ready to pull out of
town here I think that I mean over the
years I don't know if he just liked the
philosophy that's going on there with
Vantage net obviously he wants to get it
paid he want to get the extension he's
mad about that and I just think there's
III don't think Jacksonville right now
for him is a big enough market for what
he wants to do for his career yeah and I
understand that they're guys who did
that Dwight Howard did that in Orlando
you know he wanted to be bigger than
that market so I certainly understand
that I'm just I'm not sure you know he's
got to be able to read the room with Tom
Coughlin and Doug Marrone these are
no-nonsense guys they're not guys you
know who are gonna be like a you know
like Jon Gruden would go hey come on
over here hey come on let's tone it down
a little bit they don't sound like
that's the kind of guys they are their
personalities it's pretty much this is
how we do it and if you don't do it that
way then we don't want you around
because Ramsey certainly worth the
extension I just I don't know if you
know Tom Coughlin's gonna go yeah you
know what I don't like this but here's
all of this money I'll make you the
highest-paid corner
League Dan you know this I'm kind of old
school guy you know young young guy at
least now I mean some of the things that
Coughlin did in New York at work you
know he earned that respect because he
was a hard edge coach but now you have
these younger athletes and and they
don't take into a lot of being under
control and I think that says a lot
about Jalen Ramsey he's always you're
not gonna muzzle him you know I gonna
keep them from coming his personality
and you you can be as hard as you can
but I think if you try to take that
approach which I think the Jaguars have
I just think it's going to be a conflict
and I think with these today's athletes
you know I'll cover the NBA for 12 years
the same thing there that you you you
have to give them a voice and you have
to allow them to be who they are and I
think that's the difference from 10
years ago to to now that they don't
really regard that type of hard-edged
respect and origin young and you're
gonna conform to what the court you see
and I think they do did they do things
personally 2 2 2 2 2 over 2 all the
steps that type of controlling and I
think that's what's going on with Jalen
and Kauffman right now he's John Reed he
covers the Jags for the Florida
times-union joining us Dan Patrick show
how big is Gardner Minshew this morning
in Jacksonville I wouldn't be shocked if
people here put on those mustaches like
they did in Washington State I'm good
I tell you Ben it's been remarkable just
to see how this kid is come in I saw him
playing Baltimore the first preseason
game at all
tough game hit card didn't you know he
seemed like he didn't adapt too well to
the speed of the NFL and the C from that
opening preseason game to see where the
kid had now passing for about what 74
percent of his passes and just seems
like to be under control that all the
time and his accuracy is just
it's just incredible and I think I mean
I think they got something especially
with with this kid but you got a
situation at least brewing you paid
foals that money in a couple of months
is is this going to be a quarterback
controversy well I think it would be a
good problem for the Jazz you went from
no quarterbacks to two quarterbacks Nick
Foles 88 million dollars up I think when
he comes back I think he's gonna
obviously get that job I think that's
the thing that's doing I think you have
to pump the brakes a little bit for the
footage kid I mean that you know there's
a lot more games he's got ahead there's
a lot more things that he has to learn
but yeah I think when Nick Souls come
back he's going to assume that starting
job but I think this kid has had done
nothing less than impressive and and
just to have a I mean this team has not
really had a solid backup for the years
that I've covered them so even that is
in itself is a remarkable thing to say
about the Jaguars they have a solid
strong backup quarterback who can step
in for the starter and produce the way
he's producing enough and I think when
you look at the Jaguars they have a
history of having quarterback problems
and just to have something on the long
term I think it's very good for this
franchise to look down the line beyond
Nick Foles and say this is our guy yeah
probably for the next ten years and
that's something that hasn't been going
on with this franchise what uniform is
Jalen Ramsey wearing on Monday I tell
you what you know a lot of talk about he
could wind up with the Patriot I
wouldn't be shocked if Kansas City put
something together to get him you know I
see them I know it it would it might be
hesitant to give up a first-round pick
but you're looking at a franchise and
Kansas City that looking for I mean
they're patting themselves on what do we
need to do to get over the hurdle
against Patriots well here's this corner
back here that can
you can do it all let's go out and get
them I would not be shocked if something
come on the line with a tenth of city or
someone like that to go go after Eli I
do say this Dan
I think his time is done here you know I
know he played in a game last night you
know I don't think you can mend the
fences with Jason Ramsey and Tom
Coughlin and whatever going on with Matt
Schmit and the issue is not with Doug
Marrone the issues with Tom Coughlin the
management and I don't think you can be
in that fence John thanks for joining us
this morning we appreciate your time
thank you that's John read covers the
Jags for the Florida times-union for
more Dan Patrick show tune in the
audience Channel 239 on DirecTV stream
for free on BR live or download the Dan
Patrick show app
[Music]